so I could spend a lot of time talking
about Marianne's bio but she's she's
she's so accomplished and so wonderful
one thing that I know she's very proud
of which is a recent award she's gotten
it's called the Christopher Columbus
award for intellectual discovery which
she received for her work around global
literacy not only in Ethiopia and Uganda
South Africa India but also here in the
rural US please give a warm round of
applause for tonight's wonderful speaker
Mary Ann Woolf
[Applause]
thank you so much thank you for
everything that you've done for all of
us thank you Alexander
rose and Michael who's been just a
wonderful you you've been my Beatrice
thank you and Andrew and Catherine
wherever you are thank you so much well
we are going to take a very quick
journey through the human reading brain
together
I am always one of a group I never do
anything without even at least one
30-second thank you to all the people
who do this work these are people who
are in genetics they're in neuroscience
they're in education they're in
linguistics all of us work together to
bring the information I will be showing
you today tonight now it's going to be
kind of like three stories three short
stories one of them however is more like
a grim fairy tale and you will see it is
in the middle there are things that I
will say to you that will make some of
you very uncomfortable I hope you
remember what st. Thomas Aquinas said
when people disagreed with him iron
sharpens iron so at the end of my talk
please
I'm willing to be shocked and so but not
until actually the talk will have three
parts I will spend about 20 minutes or
so introducing the reading brain to you
and the implications which are very
serious for children's development and
for children who and adults who have a
different brain organization which is
dyslexia we'll be talking then about the
grim fairy tale about what this
information has to say about us and our
changes as we move evermore ineluctably
into a digital culture that will change
and has already changed us all finally
I'll be talking about one of the most
incredibly important uses of technology
in our work and that's a work in global
literacy so the first thing I want to
say is absolutely nothing nothing is
unaltered when we learn in our brain so
what people ever say this changes your
brain duh this everything changes our
brain that we are learning but there are
changes that are very important to
understand in cultural inventions
literacy and numeracy were never part of
our genetic heritage they are things
that we learned and how we are learning
about them comes from a variety of
knowledge basis and I will be pulling
many of them together but especially
these latter areas um it's a mystery
still to all of us how that any of us
ever learn to read if there's no genes
and there's no structures that are
specific how did we do this well the
answers gives us a window into how
extraordinary it is that we have this
brain that literally goes beyond itself
and now I'm going to ask
remember the audience whom I pry
beforehand he's hiding he is in the
furthest spot imaginable Alexander
however has an exposed prefrontal cortex
so it's wonderfully handy for me to use
to demonstrate a little bit thank you so
much we don't know each other but it's
very familiar to touch a man's brain but
I'm gonna do it in public but what I
want to show you is that we have no
circuits that are connected to reading
but what we do is we take areas of the
brain that were made to do things that
we do genetically have our ability to
recognize faces objects these are all
taking place here and what we are doing
with reading is we're making totally new
connections with areas of the language
here and here as you see what Otto did
so all of these areas that were not
connected are now connected in a
terribly intricate beautiful circuit but
Alexander is very tall but I'm gonna do
this anyway Oh wonderful this is what we
do very quickly we put all these
processes forwards but when Alexander
Britain's brain begins to have insights
and reads totally the entire circuit on
both sides is actually functioning thank
you so much you're very kind
thank you but there are two other
aspects so the first principle on how we
learn to do anything like numeracy and
literacy we can make these totally new
connections to make a new circuit but we
can also do something extraordinarily
clever we can take neurons that were
originally made for aspects of vision
and we can repurpose them we can in fact
recycle areas of our brain and if you
remember Alexander's brain that I
pointed to first that fusiform gyrus
area is what we used and our ancestors
used to be sure that
it could recognize things install most
instantaneously and so what we are doing
in reading is we are recycling some of
our older parts but we are doing them
within the limits that were already
there
so my colleague sent us Lester Hahn uses
the term neuronal niche if you look at
all the writing systems in the world and
you would analyze in which people have
done what you see is that so many of
them rely on features from nature so we
are using neurons in our visual system
that are actually in this niche that
they were used before but they are being
expanded now this is a kind of a little
joke there are very few jokes that
cognitive neuroscientists make so this
is just your only chance practically
these are the first tablets please it's
so bad I'm telling you these Sumerians
probably Sumerians but we really think
also the Egyptians may well have been
the first but they began this wonderful
completely new invention of putting
together symbols that would characterize
our words
now the alphabetic system is really one
of the most interesting cognitively and
for those of you who want to ask me
questions later please do but it's it's
far more cognitively intricate than most
people realize but I have to whisk you
into this next slide because I want to
give you the idea the concept that our
brain is plastic the reading brain
doesn't exist it's created and what you
see here in English is a motley overview
of the circuitry there Chinese kanji
Japanese kana anyone here who speaks or
writes Japanese ah you have the most
interesting brain in the room just so
you know that brain is actually using
two
different actually more than two but two
circuit that you see one for Kanna
and one like Chinese for kanji now very
quickly what do you see immediately in
kanji that's different from English
immediately you are not the most
immediate audience I the concept here is
that a logographic it's a slow go
celebrate it's gonna need much more
visual memory and putting symbols and
meanings so what you see here is that
visual system in the right hemisphere
requires far more space if you will
cortical space and here's the principle
the writing system will rearrange make
the particulars of that circuitry so
your circuitry is actually going to be
influenced by the writing system but
that same plasticity and here on
forecasting that same plasticity will
make us change as we use different
mediums as well here's the important
principle for us to think about what we
do when we read makes a difference in
the circuit itself the brain reflects
the cognitive perceptual and linguistic
requirements of it that brain is
changing as we speak
under our fingertips don't ask me about
babies and teaching them to read at 18
months that's a question that you want
to not ask me I have opinions however
there are I use this to simply state
that every child has to begin anew if we
don't have genes if we don't have
structures just for reading every
circuit is new it's fresh now there are
many implications for that now my
colleagues and I who work at Tufts and
MIT this is our Imaging Center where we
have a child imaging sitter we are
studying what happens before during and
after reading acquisition and
studying what does the brain need this
is a real story that has both good and
bad parts in it but I'm gonna just
highlight a few orthography matters the
child who does not have exposure to
print and all the things that go into
the colorful world of pre-literacy that
is a different frame the child's are
just not hear words and we are working
in rural parts of the United States
where some of our children have 400
words only around 3 and 4 years of age
this is unconscionable but that is going
to change that brain now many people ask
me about is spelling necessary I'm just
gonna give you one little slide from
Boston Lexington Massachusetts to
describe what I think about why spelling
is necessary I can always tell when you
hit leg straight up I simply want you to
know that spelling makes representations
those representation are part of that
brain all the words you know they're
part of that brain and so when we look
and I need you to look at this slide
this is 1995 and what I would eat just
kills myself is that the data are
basically the same to almost 20 years
later what we have our children who are
you know well have a beautiful life very
privileged a working class and a welfare
system family now the last thing I want
you to translate this side is economics
equals words you and I know that's
absolutely not true but you and I also
know that children who are with parents
who have two jobs
who
barely summon enough time at the end of
the day to talk or getting less
instances of words the reality is that
they can get 32 million less words heard
that are represented in that brain now
you and I have all the privileges in the
world what do we do about a situation
that could be so simply solved if we put
our minds to it this will be one of
several questions that I ask this
audience but now I have to put it all
together
this brain here this series of brains
shows you just a motley fashion what
Auto is doing in the first 300 to 400
milliseconds when you read you are
putting together orthographic and
permission you're putting linguistic
information semantic syntactic full and
logical you're putting it all together
in about three to four hundred
milliseconds you are primed to
understand that word but just if you
remember Alexander's brain when I push
the borders over to his right hemisphere
when we go beyond just that recognition
we are doing something almost miraculous
we are putting together extraordinary
just and we're talking about 100 to 200
sometimes even three in a millisecond
we're putting together all of this
cognitive stuff that goes into what I
will be calling deep breathing in a
minute
but what I want you to think about is
that what we are doing is not unlike and
I look at Ryan my English PhD we are
doing exactly what Proust had said in
this tiny little book called on reading
which nobody reads and interestingly
terribly he said it better than any
teacher neuroscientist or linguist that
what we do when we read is that we go to
the end of the wisdom
of the author and moving tomorrow
this is my prophet Ori way of talking
about what I am calling deep reading
skills it's essential for you in this
tiny moment with me to recognize what
you do when you move from three to four
hundred milliseconds and if we're an
evoked potential territory those of you
in psychology this is the in 400 moment
this is the moment when you pull
together what you know about the word
with what you know from the world you
put your perspective of other your
perspective taking your imagery and then
you move through analogy to inferential
processes these processes make you think
completely differently you are for all
purposes her cube for our role you are
sure like you are Miss Marple but you
are doing something to that information
that changes it and from that change
comes critical analysis and very very
importantly if we are lucky if you know
to allocate time this is unconscious but
this is if we are trained to do this we
move into proofs territory where we move
into our own if you will global neuronal
work space where we think beyond the
author and we generate new thoughts this
is an this is like the revolution in our
brain this is what we want all our
children regardless of medium all our
children to do to go beyond the wisdom
now
Alberto Manuel has wonderful wonderful
things to say about background knowledge
but I chose this quote to give you just
a sense of two processes to the deep
reading processes and this being
background knowledge reading is
cumulative and proceeds with geometric
progression each new reading builds upon
what the
either has read before think about this
you are what you read and Joseph kept
saying so many people say in different
ways but I will say that's what your
brain is doing that's what you are
putting together and right next door you
are putting together perspective-taking
and I want to give you the tiniest
exercise into your own reading just for
one minute not even a minute Hemingway
was asked to write a story in six words
it was a bet though do you know this
Ryan the bet can you write a short story
in six words and he did it now it is a
serious one so I don't watch me because
you're gonna be primed to laugh don't
what you well you can laugh later but
not now once you just neutral now think
okay
this is what he said was his finest
piece of writing it is imagery it is
imagery like none other
it is perspective taking and it's
gut-wrenching use of asset this is an
extraordinary use this is what I did
this year don't even bother to try to
glance at it just glance this is just
one piece of what we do another way of
looking at it is this we are constantly
elaborating this circuitry by what we
read by what we feel by what we think
then I have to turn you with it like a
180 cerebral turn around what about
people who don't read in that same way
that we just been talking and only gonna
be able to talk three minutes about this
despite the fact it's occupied twenty
years of my life who's counting this is
a story like few others that the reading
brain gives us insight to you see the
reading brain is just so brand-new your
brains they're 40 50 thousand years old
that dyslexic brain is not about reading
reading disadvantaged it but it is one
of the most beautiful brains the species
had and it has and it's been there for a
purpose it is part of what we might call
neuro or cerebral diversity in which we
need different brain organizations so
from my standpoint this work that we've
done over the years and in looking at
the differences and here you can just
very quickly see there's a complete
difference in the time in which
information goes instead of from the
right hemisphere at the top just to the
left the right hemisphere is processing
like crazy not for everyone but for many
this is part of
strength in the rest of life it's what
makes people artists and architects and
probably if I could do a gene study of
Silicon Valley I will bet you the
propensity of dyslexia is greater here
than anywhere in the country except
maybe MIT but I will also say I study
this not simply as a researcher but as a
mother this is my first son and he is a
dyslexic artist one of the best uses of
that brain one can ever have I will talk
about my other son a little later all to
say when we put all this information
together we could do things differently
when we think about children how can we
use these kinds of information how can
we build interventions and that's what
we're doing we are reverse engineering
the reading brain to build ever better
interventions that tackle literally the
circuit that addressed the parts of the
circuit so I'm not going to tell you
more than 30 seconds but we're built
we've built this one program called
inner panel raivo intervention but all
of the characters just to give you a
Wikus little blip of it all the
characters represent a piece of the
circuit or a strategy so this wonderful
woman our spider ms ma'am stands for
many interesting meetings for those of
you in linguistics it's polysemy she's
teaching polysemy she's teaching how
words work this is just one slender look
at what I want you to know about the
implications many of my talks are all
about the implications but this talk
this talk has to go into an area that
makes it's going to make some of you
uncomfortable with me and that's just
fine I need to talk to you about the
implication
it's not for intervention as such but
for thinking about what we all are doing
as we change after eight to twelve hours
on the screen you and I know you at
least are at least similar to me in that
you are on the screen reading and the
characteristics of the screen are
different now one of the first questions
is you know now we have a very plastic
circuit that reflects what's asked of it
what are the implications inside a mil
year that emphasizes speed immediacy
multitasking continuous partial
attention so the question becomes
whether the affordances of reading on
screen will lead us to a new a very
different reading brain one in which
text length text complexity density of
thoughts density of syntax and the
readers memory and attention are
changing or challenging here is a piece
of the cognitive evidence if you will
and part of my work is to really try to
understand what those changes are from
every standpoint from the standpoint of
reading behavior fix yourself skimming
is the new way to read we zigzag you
weren't spot you browsed you grace you
are not reading in the same linear ways
that we have done before average
attention span looks about half of what
it was with implications for memory so
studies on memory and that's what of
course you consolidate when you allocate
time to it memory seems to be
diminishing by about half as well now
what are some of the sources of that do
you know how many times our youth
between well let's just say 20 are
distracted
given our 2727 times and I'm not looking
at anybody in particular this is not a
damnation this is just a fact most of
our children and youth are basically
using multiple digital devices and they
are multitasking that's a whole set of
questions I'm happy to answer I'm not
going to talk about that right now whole
lot of interesting mixed research on
multitasking but by and large they're
moving like moving like this way now
it's one thing for us who have formed
reading brains it is another thing for
our young who are distracted what are
the implications for them and I will
certainly say this is not just for them
the decrease focus attention is in us as
well and that's a very big story that
some of you might want to probe with me
afterwards but some of the interesting
things that in fact last week I did one
program on NPR in which the the nurse
was saying my reading has changed my
experience of reading has changed my
ability to immerse myself in reading has
changed what are the factors and there
are many that go into those changes but
with what please forgive me but I'm so
much less interested in you than I am
the kids and the reason is because they
don't have an already formed reading
circuitry so the question becomes
surveillant mentally well changes in
attention multitasking the sense of
immediate access to external information
not their own external information will
that change the formation of what I'm
talking about when I say deep reading
well in an essence short-circuit us with
short-circuit our next generation so the
deep reading brain for you requires that
you allocate time requires that you use
that neuronal workspace when you read
and I'm not talking about all the
all of us when we do email we are
absolutely of course we have to scan it
but the reality is there is much reading
that we are bleeding into with that same
mode of reading so on the one hand I'm
worried about adults not allocating what
they could but more importantly it takes
years of formation for for kids to
develop all of those deep reading
processes this is not this is this is
not casual this is the essence of
critical thinking my colleague at MIT
sherry Turkle said this we transgressed
not because we try to build anew but
because we do not allow ourselves to
consider what it disrupts or diminishes
that's really the point that's why I
dare to come into a technology-driven
cafe and say outrageous things I need to
be sure we all have a kind of cerebral
pause to think about are we changing
will our children change what will be
lost what will be disrupted
but I am NOT saying that we can go back
I am this is no binary message we cannot
go back but I also suggest that we
should not simply lurch forward to the
next new thing the next new thing but
rather ask the question what must we
preserve that is essential and what must
we acquire to gain what is necessary for
the 21st century child patricia
greenfield a colleague at UCLA said
something that is just so simple and so
right no one medium can do everything
every medium has its cost and weaknesses
every meaty develops some cognitive
skills at the expense of others although
the digital medium may develop
impressive visual intelligence I would
say far more than that the cost seems to
be deep processing mindful knowledge
Jacquizz ition inductive analysis
critical thinking and reflection
deep breathing that's what that's she
just meant I work when she wrote that
this is a threat this is a threat to all
of us to think that we could just be in
the middle of what seems so
extraordinary and so expansive there are
always going to be things lost unless at
this moment of time we can use the
system to redress its own weaknesses and
so the questions I'm asking with
colleagues like Katherine is mister
who's going to universe was at NYU Fox
Harrell who was here at MIT MIT I am
asking whether we can devise digital
learning systems that address issues in
attention that address these deep
reading processes that address inference
from the start so I am asking whether we
can think as a group and you are the
people who are going to think more than
I I am going to bring my particular very
selectively piece of knowledge and the
people in this room what do you
represent you need to do the work that
goes beyond what I have done or what our
group is doing in neuroscience we need
to ask whether we can help develop a bi
literate or a multi literate brain so
that children literally know and have
formed the kinds of brain and the kinds
of intelligences that you have and
plural is the word and know when to use
what and know how because learning to
read digitally is not exactly what I am
talking about for children there are so
many aspects to really learning to read
digitally in the deep in a deep reading
sense and so I bring you to my last ten
minutes together Michael will be shocked
that I'm right on time
the third story is a completely
different one I'm asking you for another
cerebral Moo or maneuver can we take
this information about the plasticity of
the reading brain can we use it to aid
ourselves to aid our own transition to
aid the transition of our children and
very important to those of us who really
understand that literally fundamentally
changes our brain fundamentally can we
take this knowledge in connection with
technology's extraordinary potential for
democratization of knowledge can we use
it to attack global literacy and so I'm
going to use my last 9 minutes to
introduce you to a project that I'm
doing with my colleagues at MIT and
Georgia State University and these are
my kids if you will in rural it's not
even can't even use the word rural the
most remote region of Ethiopia there is
no electricity all you see there is the
light from the tablet and we who are in
this area have been struggling for many
years with the fact that about 57 to 70
million children have no schools they
will never become literate there is
nothing that is even close to that in
their lives that's 57 another 150 to 200
million are functionally not ever going
to be literate that's 200 to 250 million
children what is it that we could do
with our knowledge bases at this moment
in time when so many things have changed
even in the three years that since we've
begun this project so our question
became can we create an experience that
a tablet that could help children learn
to read on their own without teachers no
matter how remote the places and so our
approach which is really
taking our understanding of the reading
brain and hooking it to big data
analytics to technology to trial driven
learning to see whether we can take it
to places like I should show you places
like Ethiopia Uganda South Africa where
we're on places where there are 60 to
100 children in a classroom so we're in
places with no schools and where places
with schools and our approach was really
just a very it's a simple concept and a
very difficult one to implement we take
our information about the reading brain
circuit and we are trying to make an app
map we've made the map but what we're
now doing we're working with developers
we're working with all kinds of people
interested in making apps that go after
each part of that circuit so that just
as we did in our intervention with
strategies that a teacher can do we're
taking apps and seeing whether we can
create this experience which will
address those parts of the circuit and
have the children learn to read on their
own that's the concept and we're you
know that's a really difficult one
this little boy received his tablet and
I have to I have to tell you this story
he is in my opinion a prodigy we went to
the village with Motorola zooms do you
remember this is three years ago do you
remember the Motorola Xoom this big
clunky thing very robust good with dirt
falling off cliffs but it was so
difficult to turn on I will admit and
those in the front row know this to be
true took me about 20-25 minutes turn it
on you really good it did all right
I was terribly embarrassed nobody knew I
tell everybody now because what happened
then is so wonderfully embarrassing when
the tablets were distributed this little
boy took it remember there's no
electricity there's nothing they've
never seen a scene they have seen a cell
phone but that's it
takes this little Motorola Xoom in four
minutes he gets it on and says I got
mine on I'm the lion huh well he is he
is our lion Prince and within one hour
this little boy had taught all the kids
in the village how to use the tablet so
by one week most of the apps were used
by one month now we're talking over 300
apps PBS helped us you know with videos
and ebooks over 300 things were already
turned on by five months this lion
Prince no how is that possible he did it
he did it and it rude oh you cannot
believe it drained the batteries I mean
it was all solar pie was a mess but the
reality is these children first hurdle
computer literacy Z within one day
second hurdle third hurdle 4th hurdles
were working on them every day language
concepts pre-literacy precursors but I
want to show you what happened in terms
of my first trip over there to do
behavioral data and I want to show you
one thing and for those of you in is you
know want to teach her here anyone a
teacher this was like watching the first
school the lion Prince and then the
older girls took over they they drilled
him it was hysterical everybody yells
and screams about drilling these girls
drilled successfully and the result was
they they're absolutely you cannot give
them a letter now remember they have no
instruments so they take sticks and they
make the letters in the dirt they work
with anything that's in their
environment and they have learned all of
their letters they can do the alphabet
backwards and forwards
[Music]
[Music]
she does not read she does site work
it's not the same we are at the cusp
with the teachers but they we we truly
think that with just a little more work
that we will get the apps to a place
that the kids could get to a place where
they can really learn how to read and
then for us the big step will be getting
them all kinds of materials so that
reading and numeracy and reading can be
used to develop STEM skills and other
forms of learning so that will be our
overall goal we're now in various parts
of Ethiopia Ghana India these are all
small small sites each one different
Bangladesh's with cell phones the others
are all tablets and then we have come to
our own backyards this is where our
children in rural Georgia and Alabama
have shown us a side of the United
States which is really tough to see
these are our kids they are they are
being wasted and technology in this
particular part of our world has proven
an enormous resource there's a article
in Smithsonian last fall on this if some
of you would like to read it the
reporter said he had never seen poverty
like this this is us this is all
together us but these children are
learning a great deal and we're very
very much
readied if you will to go wherever we
need to to see if how the uses can be
spread and used by all kinds of children
this is our latest one in Bangladesh and
I use it there just to give you one
extra piece of information the UN
Millennium Goals will not be met but
they have taught us that if we could
reduce illiteracy by a hundred 20
million people we could reduce world
poverty by 12% some of you been reading
what Pope Francis's message of late has
been it's a simple one if we can help
solve poverty in our world we will
change it will change it for everyone
it's not a religious message it is a
spiritual one but in the deepest meaning
of spirituality it's that which we can
do by putting our knowledge together and
of course for those of you who want to
argue with me I am throwing down my
gauntlet what do you think we can do
with this knowledge about the evolving
reading brain to help that next
generation so that we give antidotes to
the potential losses and new bridges to
the next stages of intellectual
development with mediums we can't even
imagine this moment just like Socrates
who didn't want us to read it's not
about the particular of technology or a
medium it's about how we want to use our
knowledge the best of our knowledge the
best of our thoughts for the next
generation and so I'm going to leave you
not with a brain but with Aristotle Oh
what guess I did it
where is Aristotle oh my god he's gone
Oh
the race of Aristotle would have said
you gods how did I lose everything
Andrew oh this is always what happens to
me you see technology hates me it's ok
it's ok we have a love-hate affair so
what did Aristotle say about the good
Society
he said that it's one thing to have
knowledge and productivity and that's
essential to a good society it's another
thing to have leisure or entertainment
and by that he means the arts culture
but he said the thing that can go
missing is contemplation and so what I
want to end with is I would like you to
be participating in contemplation and
reflection about what all this means
whether you agree or disagree with
anything I say let us all think about
what our particular contribution might
be to going into the rest of the 21st
century armed with knowledge ready for
more but not losing the preciousness of
what we have thank you so much
[Applause]
so you're not ending with anything
because we're not done with you yet
we're gonna think about your questions
I'm going to sneak in a couple quick
ones for you first Marianne tell us
about this hacker Lyon so you said he
started hacking what does that mean what
he did was he discovered that we had
built in a camera that we didn't want
anybody to turn on because it would
drain the battery and he found it he
found a few other things and he just we
do to this moment I could never do it I
could not do what he did
the other question I want to ask you is
about a term you used a lot you talked
about the circuits so so talk us through
what that mean in their different
circuit is is that the the first few
hundred milliseconds is that what you're
saying
was this framework the whole thing it's
like the scaffolding it's a if you will
it's a term that we use for everything
that comes together in any circuit so
there could be a language circuit of
visual circuit it's a there can be
mackerel circuits and micro circuits
we're talking about reading as a macro
circuit so meaning that all of those
pieces all of those centers are used
when we think even though reading is
yeah within reading but they are also
used in other potential systems so it at
least two thirds of the reading circuit
comes from parts of language so when I
talk about how the literate the person
who's literate changes their brain
they're changing the circuits within
that the connections with those parts
they have all kinds of new parts all
right who has a question out there right
here on the front
[Music]
okay so two totally different questions
one is about the genetics of dyslexia
and the you you have to understand
dyslexia is a continuum of many things
so I myself am NOT dyslexic
the father is not dyslexic but the
grandfather's on both sides that were
undiagnosed but probable not for sure a
great grandfather on the maternal side
was this is how this was uncovered and
so my research was in the history of
Indiana as someone who went from a push
cart selling tobacco to becoming a
millionaire and what was so interesting
was that he could never do his ciphers
or his letters and had to be read to he
could never learn to read so it's
fascinating that you know I may be the
reason but never mind but it's not about
I being the reason it's about the throw
of the die so if my son will have
children more than likely there will be
a strong propensity for the my
grandchildren to be dyslexic okay okay
it's strong now your other questions
about picture graphics a verse so here's
what I want you to think about remember
that brain circuit set of three brains
Chinese and Japanese the reality is that
the Japanese brain has both a
pictographic system kanji and a
syllabary okay kana so what you have in
Japanese is a brain that is able by
fifth grade to go between types of
writing systems so right there you have
a beautiful example of putting those
things together Chinese it's not simply
pictographic at all it has a lot of
interesting things so it has more of
that phoning driven knowledge than
people realize but it's by and large
much more visual obviously
in ours but if you ask me about
alphabets what you haven't even our
alphabets are different so the fridge in
the English are much closer than the
German the Dutch and the Italian with
far more regularity they use other the
same parts but more so and in English we
use more visual and attentional
processes than the than the Germans the
Dutch the serbo-croatians and the fins
fins are the best at everything the
Japanese were oh yeah okay yes so so if
you see the Japanese this is kana
but kanji so that Japanese brain is
using both okay okay I think here and
then there were you first you and then
you okay please Oh Sam's lost on this
work yes yes yes yes yes there is
absolutely correct so that's the niche
the one concept is neuronal recycling
the other is the niche that we have
plasticity within limits so it's not
just writ large it's within those right
now
[Music]
question is more haptic haptic
kinesthetic mm-hmm
you have a beautiful question it's got
many parts part of it is the kinesthetic
that I'll just say very quickly people
who really do some of the research on
handwriting or showing us that these are
connections between the motor and the
language system that really deep in the
process they also slow it down a little
bit at a time when slowing down is good
so this kinesthetic haptic dimension is
an additive thing and you're quite
interesting to me because so many of our
children when they're doing this they
are taking their sticks they're taking
whatever they can and they are actually
adding the kinesthetic we didn't do that
this is something that I think you are
really right on the the cusp of things
that we we are beginning to learn what
to do with this medium and by no means
do we know it but it's a beautiful
question and so afterwards I want to
talk to you a little tiny bit more yes
your question
[Music]
[Music]
yes that's wonderful that this is my
favorite question so we're part of a
group called curious learning and we're
trying to figure out ways how and you
can imagine we wanted everything to be
an open-source platform so
simultaneously we are helping places
that are academic institutions like
Rochester Institute or top ster MIT
where we're taking classes of students
who are working to build apps according
to our our design but we're also working
with things like games for change we're
working with tech designers we're hoping
to interest people in developing apps
for an open source platform that can be
used so that's one piece of our work
another is is trying to figure out how
people who would ask that question of
just who who are you who you know not
you but you know who asked that question
and how can we get people of like mind
to find a place we literally have people
who are coming to us from various
countries who are now going into places
that we hadn't ever even thought of Peru
and Kenya are the two newest people come
to us and say what can we do and they
have ideas and we work with them but
we're only in the beginning of this
phase and I'll say one other thing we
are interested in people trying to
figure out from their knowledge base how
that might contribute and even though
I'm not going to say where they work one
of the reasons why I wanted to give this
talk is that I could give my other son a
lecture
it's one of the dearest things and
mother can do and his girlfriend and the
boy evidence Brotherhood the girlfriend
it's all wonderful but but they are
interested in taking their knowledge and
volunteering at some level so I don't
know what you do
I barely know what my son I'm an all in
a good place but you can use your own
imaginations in ways that I can't about
what you might do and I can't tell you
how excited it gets to feel that these
tiny little efforts and they are little
this is two little villages we began in
Ethiopia but we proved we could mean we
can move so far we have a movement as
far as we want but I will tell you that
the reality now is that Peter Diamandis
whom some of you know from the XPrize
who did the XPrize on you know space
exploration and ocean reclamation he saw
these data and said that's what's gonna
be the next XPrize it's gonna be on
global learning so there are teams that
from 40 countries that are trying to
will Whittle them down and I'll I'm just
an advisor for them I'm certainly not
going to compete but that was
unbelievable I couldn't have thought
about what you know I can't think of
those terms I'm used to working with 20
to 200 children the idea that we are
trying to change millions that's beyond
me I am I am a farmer of kids 200 acres
is about it but the world is our screen
the world is our place now and each of
us have something we can do so thank you
so much that was my favorite question
don't be dissuaded I can have other
favorites okay
next all right oops I think I think
we've got time for maybe just one more
I'm gonna
I do it really fast instead of so all
right well let's get I there's a there's
actually that's Laura welter from long
now's Rosetta project Laura did you have
a question yes yeah they're important
exactly exactly right absolutely
mmm-hmm yes absolutely correct yes
[Music]
absolutely mm-hmm you know what you have
asked a book listen it is it's beautiful
if there's so many points that you have
raised from Phaedra's where Socrates
absolutely said if you learn this you
will it is a recipe his quote is a
recipe not for memory but for forgetting
that was one of the first things that
but what he was really saying is that he
worried about the youths illusion of
knowing something before they'd ever
begun now remember this is oral culture
at its best there is no argument that I
would ever make that we can't have the
highest form of intelligence and people
who do not use literacy is Socrates you
know I can almost say case study closed
but that's not really the point
the point that you're raising is the
same one that I would have raised if I
was talking to Socrates which I do
occasionally do arguing back and forth
but but the point is that the same
things you were saying about Socrates
are that I would say is what I would say
to myself to answer your question we
haven't even begun to understand just as
Socrates had begun to understand what
deep reading was possible with reading
how we could go beyond anything that he
had imagined through reading in the same
token I will say to you that I fully
expect if I if I can just live a few
more decades to see totally different
versions of literacy emerge I look at
that with the same kind of pleasure that
I hope Socrates would if he would see
now what we do but I will ask
have to play my role my Cassandra role
and say I will worry because I'm a
reading worrier so I am going to be
worried about not what we gain I think
what we gain is going to be unbelievable
man I just finished a little bit of
reading about Mark danielewski's new
work you know familiar you know house of
leaves and what he is doing I don't know
Ryan if you know this work but what he
said was that the acts of writing
thoughts is a miracle of alchemy and
this is the man who puts images and who
is really exploding the word he's
exploding it we will do that but along
the way I must safeguard what I need to
preserve I'm actually far less worried
about what we will gain than what we
will lose that's my role but you my dear
you're gonna be the one who really helps
figure out what we will gain together we
got the world you're gonna stay right
here you're gonna come up and I would
like to give you Mary Ann a challenge
going along now challenge coin for to
thank you for for speaking here it's a
little ceremony we do for all of our
speakers one more big round of applause
for Mary Ann and please stick around
talk to her more
[Music]